[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous soyez les
bienvenus dans dimanche en politique
notre invité aujourd'hui est le
secrétaire général adjoint du MoDem
également élu à la région de
nouvelle-aquitaine et à la ville de
Bordeaux bonjour Fabien Robert bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
en ce dimanche 21 mai 2023 merci avec
nous également j'ai fait son des sports
journalistes au service politique de
Sud-Ouest pour vous interviewer bonjour
bonjour Nicolas bonjour également on va
évoquer le sommaire tout de suite le
voici de ce dimanche en politique
l'actualité de la semaine les retraites
encore et toujours pas complètement à la
fin du conflit dans la rue le 6 juin les
gens seront encore dans la rue le 6 juin
à la rencontre cette semaine entre
Élisabeth borne et les syndicats on
s'intéressera également sur un plan
politique au rôle du MoDem dans la
majorité les dossiers acquittent ou en
sommes-nous en ce début d'année 2023
l'élargissement de l'autoroute à 63 la
LGV ou encore la ZF autant de sujets qui
font polémiques et enfin Bordeaux et
vous Fabien Robert ancien premier
adjoint de la ville
rendez-vous 2026 et la mairie de
Bordeaux et avec qui vous nous direz
tout la première partie de ce dimanche
en politique et donc consacrée à la
semaine politique j'ai fait ça et on
parle encore des retraites oui il faut
bien Robert la séquence est pas terminé
le gouvernement a toujours ce dossier
sur le feu le 6 juin donc une
manifestation nouvelle journée de
mobilisation les syndicats ont retrouvé
le chemin de Matignon est-ce que vous
craignez cette nouvelle épreuve de la
rue Fabien Robert on peut jamais
craindre que les citoyens s'expriment et
manifestent en tout cas pacifiquement en
espérant qu'il n'y ait pas une nouvelle
fois des violences parce que cette nuit
je crois à l'ensemble du débat il n'y a
pas de crainte ce que je constate c'est
que on a sans doute pas suffisamment
expliqué le bien-fondé de cette réforme
en réalité aujourd'hui la critique de
François Bayon de ma famille politique
que sévère qui est très solidaire tout
de même je rappelle que si nous avions
voté 100% des députés modem voter le
texte nous sommes des partenaires loyaux
libres mais loyaux et en l'occurrence en
l'occurrence voilà sur ces retraites sur
ces retraites je crois que on voit
beaucoup de gens en colère dans les
reportages on voit beaucoup de révoltes
moi ce qui me révolte c'est que pour
payer les pensions d'aujourd'hui on est
en train d'emprunter demain c'est à dire
c'est nos enfants qui rembourseront les
pensions qu'on verse aujourd'hui et ça
on n'a pas su l'expliquer je me mets
volontairement dedans on n'a pas su
expliquer aux françaises et aux Français
qu'il y a 30 milliards à peu près de
déficit que l'État injecte or il ne les
a pas et aujourd'hui quand on a déjà
3000 milliards de dettes je crois qu'on
peut pas continuer comme ça et c'est
quand même ennuyeux Fabien Robert de
tirer ce constat là alors que c'est
quand même la réforme clé c'est la mère
des réformes la réforme des retraites si
vous faites le constat vous n'avez pas
sous l'expliquer vraiment on se dit il
fallait peut-être prendre un peu plus de
temps il y a peut-être un peu moins
d'urgence c'est ce que je crois que
manquer cette séquence là non je crois
pas on n'a pas manqué cette séquence là
parce que c'est une réforme des
retraites qui a abouti toutes les autres
n'ont pas pu aboutir quasiment donc ça
veut dire que le Président de la
République a été au bout de cette
réforme qui était extrêmement importante
elle était vitale même et nous l'aurions
voté et vous savez il n'est pas interdit
c'est même plutôt un droit un devoir de
que de dire parfois quand la méthode
doit être améliorée pour la suite si
aujourd'hui on ne change pas le logiciel
parlementaire la fabrique de la loi les
mêmes produiront les mêmes effets donc
c'est plutôt de la lucidité et pas du
tout une critique gratuite où le fait de
penser que cette loi a été ratée au
contraire je crois il y a eu la
rencontre cette semaine entre Elizabeth
borne et les syndicats le 6 juin à
l'Assemblée et à la proposition
d'abroger cette fameuse réforme des
retraites notamment on parle beaucoup de
ce groupe parlementaire
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez voilà bah
écoutez
je crois que le sérieux de ce texte est
à peu près à l'image de la sincérité de
celui qui va le présenter puisqu'en
l'occurrence le député Charles Amédée de
Courson qui va plaider pour 62 ans en
2013 des amendement pour mettre la
retraite à 65 ans donc je pense quand
même que les Français ne sont pas dupe
même les députés de ce groupe ne disent
pas que cette loi va aboutir leur seul
objectif c'est déstabiliser le
gouvernement et déstabiliser le
président de la République c'est une
impasse que se passera-t-il si demain le
gouvernement tombé et bien on renombra
un gouvernement sans doute issu de la
plus grande majorité de l'hémicycle
c'est-à-dire la majorité actuelle donc
on voit bien que la logique des
oppositions aujourd'hui n'est hélas pas
le fond je crois qu'on devrait plutôt se
mettre autour de la table avec les
groupes LR p ceux qui ont des points
communs avec lesquels on peut travailler
sur des textes sur certains sujets pour
faire avancer la France en tout cas
cette proposition de là elle vise à
abroger la réforme des retraites Fabien
Robert il y a quelles solutions pour le
gouvernement soit de l'obstruction soit
dégainer l'article 40 de la Constitution
lequel article est fait pour empêcher
justement d'avoir des initiatives qui
viseraient à fragiliser les finances du
pays ou à torpiller une loi qui vient
juste d'être adoptée dans les deux cas
c'est que des mauvaises solutions au
moins en termes d'image parce que ça
voudrait dire que la majorité refuse le
débat vous préférez laquelle je crois
pas que ce soit une mauvaise solution
que de dire aux françaises et aux
Français il y a une différence entre les
lois et les lettres au Père Noël c'est
la faisabilité financière quand on
présente une loi qui va grever les
finances de la France de 18 milliards on
dit voilà on va dépenser 18 milliards
mais on sait pas où les trouver j'estime
qu'il faut reprendre la Constitution et
l'article 40 dans ce cas là n'est pas du
tout une mauvaise solution je suis la
majorité qui pourrait dégainer ça au
risque d'être accusé de faire du blocage
l'obstruction etc oui bah écoutez voir
qui parle d'obstruction parce qu'avec
les milliers d'amendements qu'on a vu
passer sur certaines lois précédemment
il y a des experts de l'obstruction et
c'est pas nous moi ce que je sais je
suis pas parlementaire mais c'est que
cet article 40 quand on le relie c'est
pas un gadget c'est pas une argusie
juridique c'est la différence entre des
lois crédibles et des textes un peu
farfelus alors ça sera le 8 juin à
l'Assemblée manifestation le 14e journée
mobilisation on l'avait évoqué tout à
l'heure un peu le rôle du MoDem
notamment c'est critique de François
Bayrou sur le à l'encon du gouvernement
qui a pas assez bien travaillé
globalement pour expliquer cette réforme
de retraite au-delà de cette critique
vous avez déjà évoqué précédemment par
le modem va être pour la fin du
quinquennat un partenaire fidèle et
critique en même temps de l'exécutif
mais en fait il y a pas de loyauté sans
liberté si on n'est pas libre on n'est
pas loyal on nous impose quelque chose
nous on a décidé parce qu'on a un
historique François Bayrou et avec lui
pendant 10 ans on a maintenu la flamme
et parfois Dieu sait qu'elle était
petite de l'idée qu'on pouvait faire une
majorité centrale contre la gauche
contre la droite ce qui nous donne
peut-être aujourd'hui d'ailleurs dans la
majorité le droit et le devoir de
s'exprimer peut-être différemment jamais
dans les moments importants les voix des
députés du MoDem autour de leur
président Jean-Paul Mathey non manqué et
Patrick Mignola avant lui donc c'est
très clair nous sommes extrêmement
loyaux mais nous continuerons de dire
qu'il est hors de question qu'à la fin
de ce quinquennat on revienne vers ce
fameux balancier droit de gauche
aujourd'hui on est peut-être les garants
de cette équilibre là est-ce que
François Bayrou joue un peu Brigitte
musique ou un petit air pour 2027 ou pas
pour la présidentielle quand il se
démarque en étant fidèle soutien on
l'entendu mais se démarque quand même
clairement du gouvernement de Emmanuel
Macron sur ce dossier là des retraites
est-ce que quelque part il se dit ne
m'oubliez pas pour 2027 n'oubliez pas
écoutez je pense que il ne se démarque
pas d'Emmanuel Macron il fait peut-être
entend des différences avec le
gouvernement beaucoup plus rarement je
crois avec le président de la République
2027 c'est loin c'est extrêmement lancé
il reste quatre ans dans ce quinquennat
et on a l'impression que pour certains
on fait déjà courir les chevaux je
trouve que ça ne fonctionne pas ça ne
fonctionnera pas François
à rien vous ne pouvez pas renoncer en
politique si en politique vous voulez
occuper des responsabilités à être
crédible il faut être en devenir et en
l'occurrence vu l'expérience de François
Bayrou vue le rôle qu'il a eu pour
dénoncer un certain nombre de
problématiques comme la dette qui
revient aujourd'hui évidemment sur le
devant de la scène comme le seul qui a
je crois expliqué très clairement les
chiffres sur le déficit des retraites et
ça n'a été remis en cause par personne
je crois que tout ceci lui donne un rôle
singulier effectivement pour l'avenir
est-ce que ce qui peut incarner une voix
de la sagesse pour 207 de l'expérience
disons plus que de la sagesse ou pas
dire qu'en quand on est jeune on est
passage mais de l'expérience peut-être
pour assurer peut-être un pays avec une
configuration qui s'annonce assez
étonnante en tout cas la politique a
pris une telle tournure avec beaucoup
d'instabilité de manque de recul que oui
François Bayrou aujourd'hui on le voit
bien d'ailleurs même sur vos plateaux
chez les journalistes jouent un rôle
singulier quand il a une parole elle
porte elle est écoutée aujourd'hui nos
concitoyens se détournent tellement vite
et fort de la politique que je crois que
oui cette parole va compter demain je ne
suis pas d'abord à la place de François
Bayrou je ne sais pas ce qu'il a en tête
et il y a surtout du travail maintenant
pourtant vous nous l'avez dit certes il
reste encore 4 ans mais vous l'avez
aussi dit il faudrait pas qu'on retombe
dans le balancier droit de gauche et
c'était alternance qui prévalait avant
Emmanuel Macron il y a un souci
d'héritage puisque le président sortant
de se représentera pas alors c'est qui
on hérite pas en politique on peut en
parler à tous les échelles
je savais que Bordeaux plus tard c'est
on peut pas hériter en politique ça
n'est fonctionne pas comme ça nous avons
fait une alliance avec Emmanuel Macron
sur la base d'un programme commun d'un
accord politique et en 2027 il y aura
alliance reconduction c'est chose là se
discuteront le moment venu et on peut
pas parler d'héritage ce qui est sûr
c'est que si cette majorité
présidentielle dans son ensemble ne
réussit pas aucun des membres ne sera
bien placé pour la présidentielle donc
on est tous dans le même bateau pour
pouvoir reproduire bien évidemment il
reste quatre ans l'impopularité fait
partie des quinquennat quel président
quel premier ministre n'a pas été
impopulaire maintenant il faut il faut
garder le cap je crois et revoir la
méthode créer un choc de confiance moi
je suis convaincu qu'il faut absolument
revenir devant la population sur des
sujets forts de la richesse réforme de
la démocratie et que le référendum sera
un passage obligé nous le défendions
déjà d'ailleurs sur les retraites on va
évoquer maintenant dans la deuxième
partie de ce dimanche en politique il
vous fait bien Robert secrétaire général
adjoint du MoDem les casquettes ou en
tout cas les mandats locaux que vous
avez on va parler des dossiers Akita
vous êtes élus au conseil régional de
nouvelles Aquitaine le 1er dossier très
polémique du moment c'est
l'élargissement de l'autoroute à 603 la
consultation publique vient de s'achever
globalement il y a une opposition très
forte des élus du bassin d'Arcachon au
fameux péage autour de cette autoroute
A660 quelle est la voie de position là
dessus je me suis déjà exprimé j'ai
comme à peu près tous les élus locaux
considérés qu'il ne fallait pas de péage
parce que je vois pas comment on peut
expliquer qu'on va payer pour aller
bosser voilà pour faire simple je vois
pas comment ça peut fonctionner mais on
a peut-être oublié en France que les
routes ne sont pas gratuites
on l'a complètement oublié et on voit
bien aujourd'hui les impacts de la dette
parfois la dette ça a l'air extrêmement
abstrait et quand l'État n'a plus les
moyens de financer les infrastructures
on se tourne vers le contribuable et
donc directement ou indirectement ouvert
l'usager on est en train de la
rembourser la dette parce que la réalité
ça vient on a tous le sentiment parfois
que des équipements publics ne sont pas
ne devrait pas et on comprend pas
pourquoi les investissements sont pas
réalisés 3000 milliards de dettes donc
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas
réaliser ces travaux en faisant payer
les gens donc l'état les réalisera et ce
sera sans doute un peu plus long voilà
une position je crois sera celle qui
sera retenue à l'arrivée les travaux
seront peut-être pas uniquement des 7
premiers kilomètres ils seront peut-être
un peu plus longs mais entre 50 et 300
millions
on peut pas choisir 300 millions
facilement je suis pas dans le groupe
yote j'essaie d'avoir des des recettes
en face des dépenses
encore une fois les mobilités là c'est
des feux et lancer donc c'est cette zone
faible émission qui pose beaucoup de
questions parce que beaucoup de
véhicules vont devoir en sortir
notamment pour la périphérie bordelaise
on voit bien que Bordeaux métropole
cherche une solution le département la
région tout le monde va essayer de
chercher des aides des enveloppes à
fournir comment on fait Fabien Robert
alors en quelques secondes le sujet est
complexe mais en tout cas il y a un
rendez-vous environnemental aussi
écologique derrière cette cette mise en
place de la ZFE au contraire du Parisien
titre aujourd'hui sur une question à
savoir la mort d'un très jeune enfant
qui aurait été exposé la pollution et
les parents
un procès et nous avons une école des
écoles partout qui sont près d'un
certain nombre de Redon je crois qu'on
peut pas ignorer ce sujet s'ils sont
morts par an à peu près en Gironde on
doit pouvoir moins polluer sans exclure
pour ça à mon avis il faut que les gens
qui ont un vrai problème avec leur
véhicule puisse être accompagnés aidé
aujourd'hui le compte n'y est pas
financièrement surtout que si on aide
les gens qui sont dans la métropole mais
pas ceux qui sont à l'extérieur on aura
raté vous êtes la cible principale et il
faut que ceux qui viennent rarement dans
la métropole puisent tout simplement
garder leurs vieux véhicule parce que le
coût écologique d'un nouveau véhicule
serait beaucoup plus fort donc on a on a
quelques règles à poser et en allant
très vite sur ce sujet très compliqué le
vrai sujet ensuite c'est de montrer le
résultat de ce travail si on montre pas
aux gens que la pollution a diminué on
aura des difficultés à la faire accepter
or la mesure de la pollution est un
problème aujourd'hui qui paye Fabien
Robert fait on se tourne vers Bordeaux
métropole et le son président oui on se
tourne vers Bordeaux métropole j'ai
proposé au Président Rousset également
de participer il a la région décliné
très rapidement je trouve que c'est une
erreur parce que si l'artisan de
Dordogne ou le marchand de fruits et
légumes du Lot-et-Garonne peut pas venir
dans Bordeaux on va avoir un sentiment
d'indignation de révolte qui sera fondée
et là c'est pas Bordeaux métropole qui
peut aller accompagner ces personnes là
alors rappelle que ces ZF entra en
vigueur au 1er janvier 2025 quel
marchera 365 jours sur 365 c'est quand
même l'actualité de la semaine se
faisait je l'espère pas parce que nous
plaidons pour qu'on évalue la modularité
peut-être qu'en faisant des d'abord la
semaine on peut se permettre le week-end
d'autres modes de déplacement voilà et
elle sera laissé en tout cas être la
mise en pratique en tout cas avec mes
vertus très pédagogiques en 2024 vous
craignez un sujet de démocratie d'accès
notamment à la ville centre etc enfin
tout ce débat là qu'on a depuis quelques
années parce que il va y avoir des aides
mais les aides ne règlent pas tous
même quand on vient pas à Bordeaux
souvent on ne veut pas être privé de la
possibilité d'y venir c'est ça la
réalité parce que c'est la capitale
départementale régionale donc oui je
crains si ce n'est un problème
démocratique de l'indignation tout
simplement des gens qui ne vont pas
comprendre et puis la désinformation
faisant son travail on va transformer
tout ça en n'importe quoi donc je crois
qu'il faut aussi beaucoup de
communication là aussi on n'est pas à la
hauteur il faut un vrai plan de
communication régionale sur ce que ça va
représenter et l'autre difficulté c'est
que l'État a donné beaucoup de souplesse
aux collectivités sur cette loi résultat
chaque ville fait la ZFE à la carte et
ça c'est pas possible alors il y a
l'agglomération bordelaise qui sera
concernée mais l'agglomération de Pau
également sera concernée en région
Aquitaine et un autre chantier qui est
aussi très sensible un sujet sensible
c'est celui de TGV alors vous défendez
vous la ligne le prolongement de la
ligne en tout cas vers Dax et Toulouse
ça fait polémiques vous le savez il y a
beaucoup d'oppositions notamment sur le
plan des élus dans les Landes et dans le
sud gironde pourquoi vous êtes pour vous
je crois que quand on fait le constat
que pour une distance plus de deux fois
inférieure on met autant de temps en
train pour aller à Berlin pour aller à
Madrid si on prend une carte de l'Europe
on voit qu'il y a un problème voilà
c'est toute une partie de notre
développement et notre histoire vers la
péninsule ibérique qui est empêché alors
que le succès de la Paris Bordeaux est
évident donc c'est un projet qui qui en
plus concerne le mode de transport le
plus écologique l'un des plus
écologiques le train le plus capacitaire
le plus rapide et donc oui je pense que
c'est un projet d'avenir je pense qu'il
sera réalisé dans quel temporalité à
quelle échelle et il est complémentaire
du train du quotidien puisque si on veut
développer le fret et le train du
quotidien il faut que la ligne existante
soit préservée si on rénove la ligne
existante vous la mettez en travaux il y
a 140 passages à niveau à changer plus
une série de courbes qui ne sont pas
conformes au nouveau train mais on part
pour des années de travaux sans aucun
train qui circule c'est pas réaliste la
pédagogie à l'Europe non notamment pour
ce que vous appelez les campagnes de
désinformation des entiers LGV je vous
cite en fait oui
je demande des informations des
informations absolument parce que on
explique qu'on peut rénover la voix à
l'ancienne voie et ça n'est évidemment
pas vrai je demande plutôt que les élus
locaux qui connaissent le bénéfice de
ces aménagements et le courage de les
défendre y compris dans les endroits où
forcément les travaux vont être un peu
difficiles c'est pas très facile
aujourd'hui de porter ce projet dans une
partie de la région j'en suis très
conscient mais on enverra les bénéfices
à terme donc je crois qu'il faut le
porter tous ensemble courageusement et
de ce point de vue là il y a une large
alliance dans l'hémicycle régional tant
de la part du gouvernement qui a
ressorti le dossier que d'Alain Rousset
qu'il a pas vraiment défendu au
précédent mandat parce qu'il avait les
vers dans sa majorité mais qui
maintenant le défend voilà il y a une
clarification entre la gauche socialiste
et les Verts Fabien Robert oui il y a
une clarification mais à la région dans
peu de temps on va parler de de
d'ouverture à la concurrence des TER et
là la majorité régionale va se diviser
sans doute donc il y a quelques clivages
nups encore à l'intérieur de la majorité
vous parlez d'un Rousset il y a quelques
instants je voudrais que l'on termine
cette deuxième partie de l'émission par
l'évoquer à lui le président de la
région de nouvelle Aquitaine alors il se
dit vraiment fort ement qui serait déjà
candidat sa rédaction en 2028
alors il faut
intoxication
bon je pense qu'il faut poser la
question à la Rousset d'abord c'est à
lui de dire s'il est candidats et c'est
pas moi d'y répondre mais
je crois qu'il y a une question
fondamentale qui se pose à chaque
scrutin et c'est la question d'être en
phase avec une époque si je voulais
paraphraser Chateaubriand je dirais pour
être l'homme de sa région il faut être
l'homme de son temps et ça pose question
de ce point de vue là je pense parce que
à la Juppé est parti en lui disant
lui-même d'ailleurs sur un certain
nombre de compréhension d'enjeux du
monde qui nous entoure je sais pas si
moi j'aurais la prétention de toujours
tout faire bien après l'avoir fait
souvent et longtemps ouais on peut vous
faire la même remarque que pour François
Bayrou oui mais j'ai pas parlé d'âge
j'ai pas parlé d'âge ça n'a rien à voir
pour moi je n'attaque jamais l'âge les
choses
et le fait de comprendre son époque sont
de choses absolument différentes je
n'attaque jamais là je considère que ça
d'ailleurs ça n'est pas un sujet que
nous citoyens en réalité regarde de près
l'âge
je suis convaincant je ne sais pas je ne
fais pas ce comparaison entre les deux
mais je suis convaincu en tout cas que
il y a une forme d'habitude qui s'est
installée à la région nouvelle Aquitaine
de projets qui ronronnent alors que
François Bayrou propose assez
régulièrement avec le plan des noces
stratégiques et des actions plutôt
visionnaires oui je crois alors on va
terminer cette émission par la troisième
partie de ce dimanche en politique on va
parler plus concrètement de vous encore
fait bien Robert à Bordeaux notamment à
voir d'abord revenir sur le livre que
vous avez publié il y a à peine un mois
sur la campagne d'Emmanuel Macron vous
étiez à l'intérieur du réacteur trois
mois dans la campagne d'Emmanuel Macron
ma question est double qu'est-ce que
vous en gardez comme souvenir et est-ce
que ça peut vous servir à vous sur un
plan personnel au niveau politique de
voir de l'intérieur comment ça
fonctionne vraiment
une campagne présidentielle c'est
forcément une aventure exceptionnelle
parce qu'en fait on l'oublie mais c'est
un sport d'équipe on a des militants qui
défendent bénévolement matin midi et
soir leurs idées ça peut paraître un peu
naïve de dire ça mais la politique ça
reste ça fondamentalement si on peut le
désirs exactement Paul des élus donc on
a récolté les parrainages dans un
contexte très compliqué et puis bon bah
c'est un sport d'équipe mais la
politique mais des fois l'adversaire est
pas toujours en face et parfois il est
derrière vous bon c'est comme ça il faut
il faut aussi le dire il faut pas être
naïf mais je trouve que cette campagne
m'a permis de voir et de confirmer que
quand le politique s'expose et quand il
va au devant des citoyens parfois pour
se faire engueuler et bien on construit
plus facilement la paix sociale après le
jour où ce livre est sorti le président
de la République déclaré qu'il aurait dû
peut-être plus s'impliquer dans la
réforme des retraites j'ai pour ma part
constaté toute la campagne qu'il y avait
plutôt une longue campagne donc c'est ça
au fond le principal enseignement c'est
que il faut absolument être au contact
est-ce qu'il est en train de faire je
crois aujourd'hui d'aller dans le bon
sens cette non-campagne vous la mettez
au crédit d'Emmanuel Macron je la mets
au débit de tous les candidats qui ont
contourné le débat
tous les suiveurs de cette campagne
c'était quand même un des mots qui
revenait c'était enjambé la
présidentielle pour Emmanuel Macron
tourner cette page mais pas forcément
débattre aller au plus vite c'était ça
en fait je crois pas refait le film je
crois pas que président de la République
est dit ça beaucoup l'ont traduit comme
ça enjambée je crois pas que ça
fonctionne en revanche jamais ça ne
fonctionne on peut pas enjamber les
Français préfèrent des débats de la
différence plutôt que d'une certaine
manière du dédain ou du mépris parce que
ça a été parfois interprété comme ça
parce que vous pensez que
l'incompréhension sur la réforme des
retraites est aussi née de ce non débat
pendant la Financière parce que cette
proposition là elle arrive pendant la
transidentiel j'en suis devant mais
c'est devenu l'argument numéro 1 du
candidat Macron j'en suis assez
convaincu à vrai dire je pense que
d'abord quand on vote pour un projet on
n'est pas d'accord avec tout ce qu'il y
a dans le projet et ensuite entre le
projet électoral et sa mise en oeuvre il
y a toujours évidemment des différences
et c'est normal et c'est sain je pense
que nous avons peut-être collectivement
parce que Marine Le Pen s'est caché dans
les débats parce que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui n'est pas le fait d'Emmanuel Macron
donc tout ce contexte là a fait qu'on a
beaucoup moins parlé de sujets
domestiques mais on a parlé de sujets
fondamentaux l'Europe la guerre
l'énergie la santé et peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui on le paye un petit peu
c'est pas la seule raison la crise de
représentation qu'on a en France
beaucoup de pays développés à travers
faut prendre aussi un petit peu de recul
pour voir ce qui se passe ailleurs et
considérer que malheureusement c'était
un phénomène mondial Fabien Robert
Bordeaux 2026 les élections municipales
alors là on a parlé 2027 on redescend
2028 succession dans les Rousset 2027
celle d'Emmanuel Macron 2026 celle
potentiel de Pierre Mick vous avez été
adjoint premier adjoint dans ce ville de
Bordeaux ce que vous serez candidat en
2026 vous allez me dire que c'est trop
tôt
je pense vraiment que même si je vous
remercie de cette question c'est
totalement prématuré d'une part il reste
trois ans
c'est plus près de la mimanda que de
demain quand même et en l'occurrence je
pense que ça serait assez déplacé voire
contre-productif parce que je voulais
cavalier seul c'est reproduire 2020 et
moi ce que je veux avant tout et mon
énergie aujourd'hui elle est consacrée à
ne pas revivre 2020 c'est un message que
vous passez à Nicolas Florian qui lui
donne là quand même le sentiment d'être
clairement déjà en campagne
c'est un message à qui je que je passe à
tous ceux qui seraient tentés par
l'aventure seul je l'ai dit lors des
départementales partiels de Caudéran que
l'Union plus tard c'était l'Union trop
tard donc je serai évidemment engagé
dans ce combat je me sens libre légitime
mais je sais que il n'y a de victoire
qu'avec l'Union pas l'union de partie
mais tous ceux qui ne se retrouvent pas
dans la politique de pierre urmik qui
évidemment ne sont pas aux extrêmes je
pense qu'on doit pouvoir s'unir autour
la valeur on n'est pas là pour d'une
candidate bien sûr mais ça viendra mais
si on commence par le qui on ouvre le
bal des égaux et le bal des égaux c'est
stérile à 3 ans de l'élection donc je
pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui déterminer
ensemble nos valeurs il vous faut pas 3
ans pour régler cette question que vous
n'avez pas été capable de régler la fois
d'avant on aurait pu poser cette même
question aux opposants de gauche à
l'époque que nous avions et le problème
de leadership n'a pas empêché
il l'a fait quand l'Union six mois huit
mois avant maximum et Dieu sait que ça a
été difficile vous en avez fait
d'ailleurs des papiers et des papiers
donc je crois que trois ans avant je le
répète savoir qui est peut-être un tout
petit peu moins important que de savoir
derrière quoi nous allons nous unir pour
le modem il vaut mieux s'unir avec
Renaissance avec ton magasin par exemple
potentiellement on va dire Nicolas
Florian DLR ou pas le choix est-ce que
le choix il est aussi là en terme
d'idées même si on sait que sur un plan
local c'est pas forcément la meilleure
présentation et les mêmes débats qu'au
niveau national mais quand même c'est
pas du tout les mêmes débats moi je
raisonnerai pas du tout au niveau local
en termes d'étiquette je sais que les
deux princip gros groupe d'oppositions
celui dans lequel je siège Bordeaux
ensemble Bordeaux ensemble présidé par
Nicolas Florian et celui présidé par
Thomas Cazenave et tous ceux parce que
ça ne suffira pas il faudra aussi à les
convaincre des gens qui ont voté pour
Pierre-Louis quand on veut gagner en
politique après avoir perdu il faut les
convaincre des gens qui n'ont pas voté
pour nous la dernière élection et se
rassemblement là évidemment devra se
faire avec toutes les composantes
politiques et les personnes que vous
avez cité ça peut paraître illusoire
mais je crois quand même que ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui à Bordeaux ce qui se
passe pas d'ailleurs le bilan
l'immobilisme aujourd'hui réveille un
petit peu les opposants au bon sens du
terme parce que je crois qu'on peut
s'unir la ville a changé en profondeur
elle a voté quand même pour un maire
écologiste c'est une grande première on
connaît l'historique à Bordeaux de ville
de droite on arrive à mis-manda un mois
ça sera la mi-manda de Pierre rummik le
regard sur cette première partie de
mandat
négatif
diriger partager moyen en résumé ce que
j'entends le plus autour de moi est-ce
que je vois dans l'hémicycle municipal
ce qui se passe pas grand chose et avec
des gens d'ailleurs qui disent au fond
bah on avait peur mais au final Bordeaux
est resté Bordeaux etc moi je crois que
l'immobilisme est jamais une option face
aux enjeux qu'on a devant nous jamais
une option or en termes de projet pardon
mais prendre un exemple emblématique que
n'avons nous pas entendu sur le
caractère minéral de la place pey-berlan
interroger les bordelaises et les
Bordelais dans la rue pour savoir s'ils
ont noté que la place Pey-Berland avait
été mise en travaux puisque c'est fait
vous l'avez remarqué il faut un peu plus
de temps vous planter des arbres qui
poussent pour faire de l'ombre ah non
pour planter des arbres on en a planté
une douzaine à peu près mais il faudra
on peut planté je dis pas qu'il faut
qu'ils poussent plus vite je dis juste
que aucun bordelais aucune bordelaise
n'a remarqué que cette place avait été
transformée pourtant elle était au cœur
des débats on pourrait parler des
paquebots de croisière qui continue de
venir à Bordeaux ces difficultés donc
c'est le la différence abyssale et qu'il
y a entre les actes et les paroles
électorales et quand on émerge oui on
peut avoir un discours pragmatique et
des actes plus pragmatique c'est
pas que les paquebots n'arrivent plus à
Bordeaux non je n'attendais pas ça mais
en revanche ça a été promis comme
beaucoup de choses d'ailleurs qui ne se
réalisent pas et cette immobilisme et ce
cette non réalisation des projets
contraste avec quelques décisions parce
qu'il y a quand même des décisions qui
sont prises et ça pour moi c'est assez
capitale la ville aujourd'hui agrave les
crises que nous connaissons au niveau
national au lieu de les plutôt de les
amortir trois exemples très rapides
inflation on augmente les tarifs des
musées de la cantine et on augmente les
impôts nous prouverons au prochain
conseil municipal parce qu'il y a un
reliquat sur 2022 que c'était absolument
inutile les Bordelais seront choqués
quand ils verront le surplus de 2022
alors qu'on va leur augmenter leurs
impôts
prise de logement des impôts locaux n'a
rien à voir avec la crise de coït
dire que c'est un peu la théorie de la
droite de dire que l'élection de
pierre-hermique est dessus est un
accident en réalité il y a les
législatives
un autre écologiste a été élu donc ça
veut dire qu'il y a quelque chose qui se
passe à Bordeaux je veux revenir
là-dessus passer fondamental
je m'attaque et nous n'attaquons jamais
la légitimité des élus en fonction de
leurs résultats rendez-vous compte si je
devais parler de l'élection du taux de
participation municipal est-ce que je
pourrais dire pierre hormis qui est
totalement légitime son élection n'est
pas du tout un accident en revanche oui
la sociologie bordelaise aujourd'hui
parce qu'il y a le contexte du
changement climatique c'est porté vers
une liste qui a beaucoup promis mais qui
fera peu aujourd'hui on le voit vous
savez à la mimanda quand les projets
sont pas au moins lancé voir en train de
se réaliser il ne verront pas le jour
dans le mandat
je peux vous promettre que aujourd'hui
la décision publique elle n'est
malheureusement pas tout à fait
l'accélération et c'est d'ailleurs un
problème et je pense que nous verrons
très rapidement qu'il y aura eu
quasiment rien pendant ce temps là je
répète Bordeaux mérite mieux Bordeaux
mérite mieux qu'une forme de
décroissance assumée que moi j'appelle
régression
on va poursuivre quand même il nous
reste une minute Nicolas même pas 40
secondes bon simplement donc trop tôt
pour 2026 on voit néanmoins que les
arguments sont prêts on en revient quand
même à cette question de l'Alliance
Fabien Robert c'est vous y revenez oui
effectivement à l'alliance mais vous
avez 30 secondes c'est très simple
toutes celles et ceux qui ne se
reconnaissent pas dans la politique de
Pierre urique et qui seront demain qui
ne sont pas aux extrêmes qui sont
pro-européens qui sont pour une
croissance respectueuse de l'homme et de
la planète qui pense qu'au Bordeaux
mérite mieux et je crois que toutes ces
femmes et toutes ces hommes là doivent
se rassembler aujourd'hui autour de
valeurs pour demain on est porté un
projet commun entre le entre Renaissance
votre allié à l'Assemblée et l'air votre
alimentation je pense qu'il faut tout le
monde si nous n'avons pas tout le monde
et c'est pas des étiquettes dont je
parle c'est peut-être des gens qui ont
cette étiquette en France il faut
absolument tout le monde pour gagner ces
millions c'est le rassemblement merci
beaucoup
aujourd'hui je vous rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire général adjoint du MoDem
merci j'ai fait un espèce
bon dimanche à toutes et à tous merci
[Musique]
très singulière une activité c'est